[Music]
Welcome to the Working Intelligence Podcast,
part of Working Intelligence, the AI Optimism
Project. I'm Jordan Hirsch, and I'm honored to
be joined by my friend and fellow Palunteerian,
Mike Gallagher. Mike spent seven years in Congress
representing the 8th district of Wisconsin, served
in the Marine Corps as an intelligence officer
with two deployments in Iraq and holds a PhD
from Georgetown. We're recording this podcast on
the eve of the 24th anniversary of September 11th,
a hinge point in our history and proving really
that our fight was not over after the end of the
Cold War. It demanded the grit and ingenuity
of the American people to adapt and overcome.
And today we stand on another hinge point facing
new challenges from powers like China which
demands every ounce of that grid and ingenuity
supercharged by artificial intelligence. We're
going to talk to Mike today about that evolution.
Mike's really somebody who's lived that evolution
from the start of the postcold war period until
this point and talk about how American workers
rose to meet the challenge of that era and how
AI can empower them to meet the challenges that
we face today. So Mike, really glad to have you
here for this podcast and an important moment
for us to to reckon with the history of 911 and
couldn't think of anyone better to do it with. So
on that note, why don't you just start by asking
you on the 24th anniversary, what did 911 mean
to you in your career? I assume it was somewhat
formative and and perhaps the reason for your
various forms of of public service, but would love
if you could reflect a little bit on your decision
to serve in the Marines and to run for Congress
and what effect 911 had on those decisions. Well,
first of all, Jordan, it's an honor to be with
you and it's an honor to be called your friend in
addition to your colleague. I've long admired your
work and we've c before we worked together here at
Palanteer, we crossed paths in various, you know,
efforts to improve American national security. So,
it's always fun to be with you. Um, I would say,
well, first of all, it's it's crazy to think that
it's 24 years ago. It does seem less far removed
than that in my own mind. I was a senior in high
school when 9/11 happened. I remember vividly,
this was, you know, data. I'm now like old,
particularly at a company like Palunteer, like,
you know, 41 basically means you're both. Um, but
this we had just like gotten big projector screens
in the classroom which was a massive like deal
uh in terms of e education technology at the time.
And so I remember what the the plane hit the first
tower while I was still at home cuz I was on the
west coast and then when I got to zero period the
second plane it hit but then I watched the towers
crash to the ground. um in my American government
class at the time, AP American Government. Um and
I I mean obviously it was instantly palpable and
clear that this was a sort of a historyaltering
event and a incredibly somber and tragic event.
That being said, it wasn't as if I immediately
knew, oh my gosh, I have to rush out, find a
Marine Corps recruiting station, put on a uniform.
I mean, it's still I was lucky enough not to have
anyone in my immediate family directly affected by
it. Although, my brother-in-law, who was not yet
engaged to my sister, was working in the Twin
Towers on a floor above where the plane hits,
but happened to sleep in that day, crazy enough.
And there's, you know, thousands of stories
like this. Um, but it still seemed like I didn't
immediately connect the dots in terms of what was
my part in the response. Obviously, it took some
time for our country to work out um the response.
It wasn't until I went to college the next year
um and we got more wholesomely engaged in the
Middle East, particularly after the invasion of
Iraq, uh that I started to think about, okay,
what are we doing? Like, what is this problem
we're grappling with in terms of Salafi jihadists
that want to kill us and destroy our way of life?
That seems odd because we're America. We're great.
We have no enemies. History had ended, etc. Um,
and the more and I actually got so interested
in that I changed my major. Uh, and I started
studying Arabic and the Middle East. And the
more I pulled that string intellectually and the
more I learned about the region and I wrote a,
um, a senior thesis examining uh, terrorist uh,
groups and their involvement with civil society
organizations, I just became fascinated by the
Middle East. the more I started to think about,
okay, maybe practically uh maybe this is an
opportunity to use these skills and put them to
use for the country and that that would be better
for me and for the country than going to Wall
Street and just like shifting numbers around on a
spreadsheet. No offense to all my friends who did
that. Uh and then secondly, you know, the country
was at war. I didn't come from a military family,
but I felt like I had had I'd been pretty lucky um
to grow up in a you know with a lot of advantages
um attend some great schools um and then I
felt like I had a debt I needed to repay to
the country and I knew I would kind of look back
and regret it if I didn't step up and serve.
Uh I'm also kind of a bit of a contrarian by
nature and so at the time it was not fashionable
if you were at an Ivy League school to join the
military in general. Particularly by the time I
went to officer candidate school this was really
when the war started going badly uh with the Samar
Mos bombing was in 2005 2006 the bottom fell
out of the country. This was like you know the
the anti-Iraq war fever started to reach a fever
pitch. So it was kind of a contrarian move. There
hadn't been we had an ROC program at Princeton,
but nobody had joined the Marine Corps, I think,
for a couple years. So I just I was intrigued by
doing something totally different. Uh and everyone
was like, "What are you doing? What why are you
joining the Marine Corps?" I also wasn't, you
know, this may shock you to learn Jordan. I wasn't
like an athletic stud or anything, you know,
I was very much a bookish nerd my whole life. And
so it took a lot of time for me to develop like
literally develop the muscles necessary to join
the Marine Corps. And so I don't know that there
was like this circuitous path would be the short
answer to this question from 9/11 to my own like
small small small small role in fighting uh what
became the global war on terrorism and and being a
small small small part of our country's response.
And I'm I'm happy to unpack that further. But the
final thing I'd say is like it was absolutely, you
know, besides marrying my wife, the best decision
I've ever made in my life. It was just the Marine
Corps, particularly for someone who didn't know
anything about the military, wasn't an ROTC. The
way the Marine Corps has officer can candidate
school structured like it is a it gives you this
opportunity to kind of figure out if you want
to do it. And then like there I I really thought
about there there's no other domain in life where
as a 21-year-old right out of college I could be
in charge of 40 people and be thrust into this
super demanding challenging uh environment. And I
wanted that combination of like a physical test,
an intellectual test, a moral test. And it was
awesome. I loved it. I absolutely I love the
point. I think the weirdest thing for people to
understand like you know at that age when you're
young you think you're invincible. And so like
you have no you're not encumbered by anything
like I wanted to deploy like I like volunteered
for deployment so I'll shut up there. I've talked
too much. No no it's I I'm wondering I mean you
you pointed to when you joined the Marine Corps
which was really as things were breaking down
in Iraq and the strategy that we came to Iraq
with was not the strategy that we needed to to to
succeed and and ultimately be able to to disengage
from the height of the war. And I'm wondering
you and we we might all be familiar with how that
conversation played out in Washington, but you
were really on the front lines of the ingenuity
that was required to solve for that problem. And
I'm wondering what it was like for you to deploy
in the middle of this crisis as things were really
breaking down and be a part of the the shift in
the American strategy toward a more successful
strategy that allowed us to stabilize the country
and and save a lot of lives. How did that happen
from from your perspective being in the Marines?
Well, I would say two big things. One, well, one,
prior to deploying, I kind of had this naive,
quicksotic, or even arrogant idea that
because I spoke the language and I like,
you know, was a good student that I was going
to be like a modern-day TE Lawrence and like,
you know, uniquely bridge the gap between the
Marine Corps and like Onbari tribal shakes and
things like that. Uh, I was quickly disabused at
that notion. Um and I think I think there was I
had a very like simplistic understanding of the
region and even the the we the Marines were trying
to educate themselves at the time the you know
the commun reading list started to include all
these books about counterinsurgency even included
T. Lawrence's memoir um seven pillars of wisdom
and some of these books like the Arab mind which
now in retrospect seem totally ridiculous and like
didn't really teach me anything about like the
specific micro geography of the specific part of
Iraq that I went to which was totally different
than what was happening in Baghdad and let alone
in like northern or southern Iraq. Uh so I had to
do a lot of learning on the ground but I also got
to see it firsthand. And I got to actually see our
strategy succeed because I did two back-to-back
deployments. And in the early part of one of my
deployments, you know, the the the surge kind of
happened in Western Iraq and Ambar Province where
the Marine Corps was prior to it happening in the
rest of the country. And so we went from
at the beginning of one of my deployments,
a group of al-Qaeda and Iraq operatives crossing
the Syrian border dressed in stolen Iraqi army
uniforms and slaughtering like 50 people in the
local village and creating a ton of mayhem to
by the end of my deployment, we were, you know, we
were mostly focused on economic issues and we were
targeting oil smugglers and we were, you know, we
felt very comfortable walking around the streets
uh in some cases without personal protective
equipment. And it was just a remarkable change.
I mean, absolutely remarkable change. And
so I kind of got to see the the fruits of
our counterinsurgency strategy, particularly as it
was perfected by General Petraeus and a few others
play out firsthand and kind of see all these
fence sitters in the local tribal hierarchy,
you know, in the Al Mahalawi tribe, the
Kbouli tribe, etc. go from like, you know,
either straddling the fence or actively working
against us to realizing that America was the
strong horse. They should bet on us and help
us decimate or actually completely destroy the
lingering al-Qaeda and Iraq network. Now, that's
not to say we completely destroyed it, but it was
I mean the the success of our counterterrorism
operations and our counterinsurgency operations
was something to behold. Now, I will say I think
in retrospect it does seem clear that all of that
did was buy us time or the opportunity for
Iraqi political figures and power players to
forge a durable political uh consensus. And it
was somewhat bizarre to me when the Syrian civil
war emerged a few years later. At one point, I
think there was like Syrian airplanes bombing
the town that I was deployed to, al-Qaeda,
because there was terrorists there. I'm like,
what is going on? I mean, it's just like such
a fragile uh equilibrium. Um, but uh it was
absolutely fascinating. And um I will say like
the obvious things were true. I mean, you know,
you really have to understand the local dynamics.
You have to be present for deployed. You have to
get out of the base. You have to interact with
the local officials. That was kind of my job.
I was a commander of a human intelligence
exploitation team. And our job was to gather
information from human sources in order to get bad
guys and keep Marines safe. And so, I don't know,
it was absolutely fascinating to see the strategy
kind of work um over the course of one deployment
to the next deployment. One of the one of the
pitfalls in retrospect is that we focus so much
on counterinsurgency as a result of Iraq that we
were a little bit asleep at the wheel as another
challenger rose across another part of the world
in China and that the type of fighting that we
needed to do in Iraq made it difficult to focus
on the re-industrialization that we had kind of
given up on in the wake of the cold war and trying
to reap the the peace dividend in the wake of the
cold war. Um, can you talk a little bit about
what was China doing in the meantime while we
were focused in in Iraq and doing the kinds of
things that you were doing and how did we get to
the place where we are today where we seem to be
behind in in key metrics like ship building or or
running a pace with them when you know 20 years
ago that would have been a very far-fetched idea
that America was running a pace of anybody. Well,
first let me confess how odd it is that people
now think I know something about China because I
chaired the China committee in Congress because
most of my career I was an Arabist. I mean I
that was my that was my background my training
and and to kind of like tie it to your question
your your this question to the previous one the
first day of my second deployment I arrived in
country in route to al-Qaeda which is a town
near the Syrian border in Albar province and I met
uh a Marine who was leaving uh this my first one
I remember um and his name was Matt Pinger and
Matt Pinger had was in my same military occup
occupation specialty was the commanding officer
of what was called HET one the unit I took over
uh near the Syrian border and just fascinating
brilliant guy former journalist you know he had to
get an age waiver to join the Marine Corps amazing
story but I remember talking to him and like even
on the his he was leaving country and usually like
you know when you're about to leave country you're
pretty exhausted but Matt still had his like
boyish grin and enthusiasm for everything but
he told me his life story and he was a Mandarin
linguist, a China specialist. He spent a decade
in China. And I remember thinking at the time
like why like why would someone why would an
a an ambitious national security professional
spend their time focusing on China? Like right
China's not here. Exactly. This is where it
is. Yeah. Yeah. It's it's all the Middle East
for time in memorial. We're fighting terrorists,
you know, like what an idiot. I learned Arabic.
I'm smart. Uh but it turns out Matt was right.
Uh, and I'm not I'm not I wasn't wrong, per se,
but uh he saw something I didn't. And you know,
even when I was a Senate staffer and increasingly
um paying attention more to what China was
doing, Matt was really the source of most
of my education. And when I got elected to
Congress, I made a point of how we had a
monthly meeting where, you know, I just I kind of
went to the Pinger grad school on China. I was an
security adviser on the Walker campaign. And then
I remember Matt would send me these very detailed
memos where really he laid out the pattern of of
facts and and the corresponding strategy response
in a way that became the intellectual foundation
for the Trump administration's approach to China
in the first administration. But suffice it
to say and to directly answer your question,
um, you know, while they were that while they
were sort of publicly while we were inviting
China into the global economic order in the hopes
that it would moderate their political behavior,
uh, they were pocketing those concessions, growing
more repressive internally, aggressive externally,
and um, and really with no intent to ever abide
by the rules-based global order in general or
their specific promises that they made as part of
the session to the WTO in particular. By the way,
those aren't the musings of like some Republican
hawk. I think Rush Doshi would agree with that
assessment if you read his book. Uh the long game,
you know, was always the strategy of, you know,
hide your ambitions, b your time. Um and you
know, this this latent ambition to not only be the
dominant country in the Indopacific region, but
really the dominant country uh in the world. Uh,
in fact, you know, while historians will quibble
over when the new cold war with communist China
began, as they continue to to quibble over when
the old Cold War with the Soviet Union began,
you know, a lot of the initial aggressive island
building efforts and corresponding territorial
claims even predated Xiinping. Um, and so I
think uh I I I think what we're seeing now
is an expression or a continuation of a concerted
strategy that the Chinese Communist Party has had
for decades. Uh, and it is a strategy to destroy
the US-led global order, to displace our position
of preeminence, um, and to become the dominant
country in the world and and along the way sever
all our alliances. Yeah. So now that we're in
2025, this is the this is the big challenge that
we confront. How do you think we can close the
gap with China and the places where we've lost
ground and retake the lead? And and specifically,
what can AI do for our defense industrial base if
properly harnessed and implemented? And and I
guess the the key question here is like why is
it so important for humans to be amplified and
not replaced by artificial intelligence? Well,
in order and and maybe in in simplest terms,
how I think about this is um at a minimum like
the pass fail grade for US grand strategy is we
should not be funding our own destruction. Right?
If there's one thing we've learned like in
the last three decades, it's that, you know,
the problem isn't that we didn't engage hard
enough with China or that we didn't like give
them enough access to the global economy. It's
not like we open one more theme park or have,
you know, more American movies in China or another
American business. Suddenly the commies are going
to wake up and think, you know what, we got
America wrong. Let's change our whole approach.
like we should not be allowing US capital and
intellectual property to flow to China in order to
fuel their destructive ambitions, their genocidal
ambitions internally and their ravantist ambitions
externally. uh it is long past time for us to
put controls on outbound capital flows to China
to put sensible limits on their access and and
on their access to our own intellectual property
their presence at American universities and also
to reestablish some semblance of deterrence in
cyerspace so that the greatest transfer of
human wealth of wealth in human history i.e
intellectual property theft from China does not
continue. Um so that's point one. Uh point two,
because we were complacent uh for decades, you're
right to suggest that the American industrial base
uh and defense industrial base in particular has
become hollowed out. It's become brittle. Um we've
gone from having a lot of companies in that space
to it being concentrated in five defense primes.
Increasingly, we're starting to see that change
due to the efforts here at Palanteer to revitalize
ecosystem uh and the the new administration's
push for a nontraditional defense tech. But still,
we're not moving fast enough. So, we have to find
a way to revitalize American manufacturing. And
that's where I think AI has so much promise,
right? Far from being a threat to American
workers, I actually think AI is going to be
the Iron Man suit that we're able to wrap
around every American worker who wants to work,
bust their butt, allow them to make more money,
be incredibly more productive. And the
fact is, we just, as a matter of strategy,
we're not going to beat China if we just try and
throw more human beings and money at this problem.
We have to find a way to fight smarter. And it's
that American innovative ecosystem leveraging AI
software uh cutting edge technology pairing it
with legacy industries that I think is going to
be our opportunity to to um reduce our dependency
on China in critical areas revitalize our American
manufacturing industrial base and also ensure
that they can't control the commanding heights
of critical technology whether it's AI whether
it's quantum whether it's synthetic biotech
take your pick. Because what we've learned in
recent years is that given dominance in those
areas, they will weaponize that dominance,
right? They're using their dominance in rare
earth manufacturing and processing right now to uh
uh to kind of hold us over the barrel in certain
diplomatic negotiations. Um they threatened to cut
off the export of APIs during the uh coronavirus
pandemic to plunge us into a sea of coronairus.
Imagine if we got into a confrontation over Taiwan
with China and they cut off access to critical,
you know, micro electronics or rare earths or,
you know, ingredients for life-saving drugs. Or
imagine if they weaponized the access that they
now have to American crit critical infrastructure
after the vault and salt typhoon attack. So,
I guess all this is a long way of me saying while
we've paid lip service to the idea that we have an
existential competitor in the form of the CCP, and
while some are willing increasingly to say we're
in the early stages of a new cold war, we still
haven't attacked this problem with the requisite
sense of urgency that it demands, as if it were
an existential threat. And every time I even would
say that that this is an existential threat,
I would get the crap kicked out of me by the
Washington Post and all sorts of commentators
on TV and I'd be called a neoccarthy. But all
you have to do is just read what Xiinping says,
particularly when he's talking to party audiences.
Like he has no reservations. when he's not talking
to the Davos crowd, when he's talking internally,
about talking about America as evil, about talking
about the inevitable decline and demise of the
capitalistled order led by America, about saying,
"I will take Taiwan by force if necessary," he is
preparing his country for war, and we still are
not meeting the moment in order to deter a war.
Yeah. On that happy note, I'll stop. Yeah.
On that happy note, well, actually, well,
maybe we'll try to turn to a happy note. through
your through your work at Palanteer, you've been
able to see where the industrial base is picking
up AI to to sort of speed along and supercharge
what it's doing. I'm curious if you can share some
examples in some of the spaces where where you're
active through Palunteer or where workers are
using AI to free themselves from drudgery so they
can build better and faster and get back to the
thing that they really actually want to be doing,
which is building the things that America needs
to stay strong and to win this fight. Well, where
I'm most excited about this, um, and perhaps it's
because I represented a ship building district,
or perhaps it's because, you know, I'm a Marine
Corps officer, which means I'm a naval officer,
which means, you know, I think the Navy Marine
Corps team is, you know, the most important team
that we have. Um, but I think we have a massive
opportunity to revitalize American ship building
right now. The Trump administration has rightly
placed this as one of their highest priorities.
And uh in our work at Paler, we've already started
to see some of the positive effects that applying
actual commercial technology AI enabled software
to manufacturing can have the transformative
effect it can have. For example, at Anderoll, it's
already delivered a 200fold increase in supply
chain responsiveness. That's now accelerating the
production of unmanned service vessels, which are
critical to Indopacific deterrence against China.
Um, engineers now operate with full situational
awareness, when they're sequencing tasks, uh, uh,
when they're resolving procurement friction, uh,
when they're adapting designs in real time. At
Seronic, another great customer of ours that's
helping build a foundation for a fully digitized
shipyard. So, you're going to have procurement,
design, manufacturing unified into a single hyper
intelligent system where every input is tracked,
every decision is contextualized, every risk
is anticipated. Um, and I think what's going
to emerge on the other side of that is an
industrial shipyard machine with the agility
of a startup and the precision of a defense prime.
And this model, um, powered by Palanter software
is already scaling among America's allies.
So on the Korean Peninsula, for example,
HD Hyundai's flagship shipyard is operating at
a tempo and scale that the United States hasn't
matched in decades. South Korea now builds nearly
30% of the world ships and Chandai alone commands
17% of global output. One yard there delivers
nearly five times more commercial vessels than
the entire US ship building base combined. So
I think ship ship building for me is just this
perfect example of legacy manufacturing that's
critical to US national security where the the
new administration clearly sees it as a priority
where you're starting to see the non-traditionals
and foreign innovators do some some really
interesting things and if we can just apply
that to American shipyards I think we can we
can produce a quantum leap. One final story to
illustrate how absurd the the current situation
is visav China. I remember going to um a master
ship repair yard in Southern California um in
my first term when I was a freshman member of
Congress and they were just talking about how
they had just built a dry dock, right? Dry dock,
big structure you need to repair ships and they
were telling me and I'm like so where did where
did you build it? Like how how did it work? And
like well we built it in China. So you think about
it like we're building dry docks on the west coast
so that we have more ships to confront China,
but we have to we need China to build the things
necessary to repair those ships. And in order to
get it from the Pacific back to the West Coast,
you have to cut it into three pieces, ship it,
weld it back together. And they were like, "Oh
yeah, we almost couldn't weld it back together
because local politics were such that people were
worried about underwater welders forcing the fish
to go deaf in the harbor." And I'm like, "Come
on, America. we got to get our crap together
like this. This is totally absurd. So, you're
starting to see that change. I think we have an
opportunity right now. There's a big way in which
and I'm curious uh if you've found this in meeting
with shipyard workers when you when you've gone
to visit these sites, there's a big way in which
there's so much that we're doing to get in our
own way. And I find when we when we've been doing
these stories for working intelligence, you find
so many people who just really want to do the work
that they signed up for, whether that's treating
patients or building a product in a factory.
And what's happened over the last 25 to 30 years
is these barnacles of administration and data and
emails and spreadsheets just suck the soul out of
the work. And the real useful applications of AI
are taking that stuff off the plate of the humans
that they can be their fully realized creative
selves and and produce at their fullest and and
really derive pleasure and meaning from their work
as opposed to being bogged down in all of this
all the barnacles that have kind of glombmed on
to their jobs. I don't know if you found that in
the shipyards as well. 100%. Right. Some estimates
we've seen is that at at various shipyards,
people are doing productive work less than
20% of the time. Not through any fault of their
own, but they're like complying. And I'm sure
this is a consequence also of being government
contractors, right? You have to dealt often with
like webs of regulation and bureaucracy, but
the the consequence is that, you know, people
are spending 80% of their day doing mind-numbing,
soulcrushing work, and nobody wants to be doing
that, right? So what AI has the potential to do
is liberate people from the soul crushing work
and allow them to focus on meaningful productive
work. Um I you know it's interesting I this had
just occurred to me now so bear with me. I
reserve the right to resend the statement.
There is a way if you read like what Xiinping is
talking about, right? He he his spirit animal is
Stalin and he talks about like engineering souls,
right? Like this is sort of the Marxist Leninist
ideology that like the party can like engineer the
souls of all the party members. Like we're sort of
at Palunteer doing the exact opposite, right?
like we're liberating souls from soul crushing
work so they can realize their highest potential.
That's true in ship building. It's true in legacy
manufacturing. It's true in any industry that's
collected the barnacles that you've talked about.
And once you do that, I think you're also going
to start to solve I think the workforce challenges
get get much easier to solve. So, for example, one
thing I I confronted when I was in politics was
people paying a lot of lip service to this idea
that, well, not everybody needs to go to college,
right? Let's go into the trades. You can be
a welder at a shipyard or you can, you know,
do XYZ and make money and you can be making 85
grand a year right out of college and not have
college debt. And like, it's all it's all right.
It's all true. And everybody like was saying the
right things. But then I would ask parents saying
this, I'd say, "Well, what about your kids?"
and they'd say like, "Well, I mean, my kids are
going to go to a four-year college, you know,
because there was still this stigma associated
with the trades." Um, there was still like this
people were still playing the status game of
of four-year colleges. And so I actually think
the more that manufacturing and the trades adopt
cutting edge technology, the sexier it becomes for
that 17-year-old or 18-year-old who's weighing,
okay, I'm interested in working at a shipyard
or working in agriculture, but I still feel
this pressure to go get a four-year degree.
Or maybe like my perception of that industry
is that it's dirty, old school. My dad did it,
my grandpa did it. Like I don't know like I what
what's when you get into these companies that
have adopted Palenteer software other cutting
edge commercial technology it's really exciting
to see what like one worker uh can do and I think
that's going to be attractive to a new generation
for whom the value proposition of higher ed is
changing. You're probably better qualified to
opine on that than I am. But I just think at some
point like if your four-year degree is not getting
you like a return on the investment, like you're
going to look for alternatives. And if we can make
it culturally attractive to go into the trades
because it's technologically advanced, then I
think you start to cook with gas. Um because
every industry I represent in Wisconsin, it
really didn't matter. Their biggest challenge for
really my eight years in Congress was workforce.
They just couldn't find enough people to do jobs.
Like, so if you're willing to work hard out there,
like the world is your oyster. Like, there is
no there is no near-term possibility that AI is
going to put you out of a job if you're willing to
bust your ass because like there is plenty of work
to be done. Yeah. I think one of the frustrating
things about the messaging around AI is that it's
going to take everything away from you. You won't
have to do hard work. And actually, what we found
at Palanteer when we've worked with our customers,
it's actually really high agency enabling,
right? It actually takes the most hardworking
people and gives them all of the autonomy that
they would want. And if you're a 17-year-old kid
and you want to have a major impact, come to a
company that's using AI natively and just see your
star rise, right? Like you can do so much more and
not be burdened with all of the administrative
tasks and not be buried under bureaucracy.
It really allows the best ideas to win because
it allows them to scale at a in a way that we've
not seen before quite frankly because you can take
all that knowledge, combine it with other people's
knowledge, and as you said, you're cooking with
gas. I guess that's a great place to leave it,
you know, for for for a last question. You you
represented a a district in in Congress for seven
years. What would you say to the your your former
constituents or or or anyone else about um workers
in in your district who are afraid of losing their
jobs to AI? Why are you optimistic about American
workers leading in AI innovation to strengthen
our defense and and more broadly to lead in AI
in a in a commercial sense as well? Well, I would
say the only people who should be worried about
AI taking their jobs um are people who refuse
or don't want to learn how to incorporate it
into their day-to-day routines. Um and I think the
great news is that there's a surge of enthusiasm
about incorporating AI into into day-to-day
workflows, particularly in the manufacturing
space. When it comes to the trades, as I said
before, we have a huge shortage of workers.
I think we're something like 300,000 welders short
in the maritime industrial base. 300,000. Like
that's a massive amount. That's twice as big as
the Marine Corps. Uh so we need to recruit more
kids to go into the trades. Um so again, if you
are you willing to work hard and learn new skills,
um then I think the world is your oyster. And to
the point you made, Jordan, yeah, the work could
be as hard, if not harder, but it's going to be
more meaningful, more rewarding intellectually and
ultimately financially, allowing people to provide
for their family, which matters a great deal. Um,
I further say that, you know, AI is becoming a
selling point for manufacturers looking to recruit
students into the workforce. Um, I actually think
like the next generation is going to discover use
cases for AI and traditional industry that we
can't even imagine right now. I even started
to see it like, you know, in the district
I represented is a huge dairy uh district,
right? We there are some counties where there are
more cows than than human beings. Um, you know,
I think like your your traditional conception of
the dairy industry is like, well, okay, you know,
a mom and pop dairy, 50 cows, like eat a lot
of manual labor, like, well, actually, you go
on some of these farms and you start to discover
it's highly automated. It's highly technologically
advanced. I mean, there's like robotic milking.
There's drones that they use to like test
the soil. If you care, you know, if you're a
conservationist, there's all sorts of ways you
can use digesttors and dewatering to, you know,
deal with uh nutrients that come from cows and
things like that. So, it actually ends up being a
pretty technologically advanced industry. Uh even,
you know, milk and cows can be exciting for the
next generation. So, I don't know. This is why I
I'm an optimist. I guess the the other reason
I'm an optimist is um well, two other reasons.
want to, you know, working at Palanteer, um, you
know, as as maybe you and I are the only liberal
arts majors at this company, you're surrounded
by these geniuses from all over the country,
super young, and like it keeps me on my toes every
single day. I think, you know, I was a young I was
the one of the youngest members of Congress when I
got elected, so like I kind of thought I was smart
relative to my old peers. Now I just have to like
keep up every day and to see the problems that are
being solved by our engineers, not not by them on
their own, by the way, but working in partnership
with customers in the manufacturing space. I mean,
it's like magic when you see it happen. Like when
you pair a 22-year-old genius computer science
major from Stanford with like a third generation
ship builder in Northeast Wisconsin with all the
tribal knowledge, like it is like lightning in a
bottle. That makes me an optimist. And you
know, finally thing I'd say at the risk of
being corn corny is like America has demonstrated
a remarkable capacity for for course correction,
for reinvention, for innovation. So as much as I
spent the last, you know, near decade in Congress
warning about the China threat, I still would
bet on America 10 times out of 10. You know,
I think we have all the advantages and we have
a righteous cause. I mean, we're the good guys
and we're facing off against the bad guys. And I
think, you know, you're seeing a wave of companies
which previously wouldn't be willing to work with
the government and the defense department because
they had some moral equivalence after Palanteer
rushed into the breach and said, you know,
we are unabashedly want to help the American war
fighter. We're seeing a sea change in that in that
department. And the more we have America's best
and brightest who would otherwise be optimizing
algorithms for like, you know, social media
applying their talents to national security, the
more optimistic I become. Yeah. I no better note
to end on. And the only thing I'll add to that in
addition to being around the magic of Palunteer is
being around the magic of the people that we work
with and seeing past the headlines on AI which
are often very depressing or assuming that we're
going to either get killed or have our jobs be
killed away and seeing people who have been in the
trades for 20, 30, 40 years in some cases, people
who work on factory plants just ignore the noise
and use a new tool that's available to them and
achieve something they never thought was possible.
So it's a it's an exciting time. Hopefully we can
have people focus on on the good and and drive in
that direction. And Mike, really thank you for
joining us. Really glad to have you on working
intelligence and and thank you for the work that
you're doing to bring AI to the American worker.
Much appreciated. It's an honor. I've never been
accused of being intelligent, but nonetheless,
you got half the Yeah, I like working even if
I'm not intelligent. There we go. Thanks a lot.
[Music]